ces teams omlt situe même peut-être
maman aussi allez viens je t'emmène j'ai
hésité un instant maintenant je te le
dis comme aujourd'hui je suis ton amour
ma liberté chérie la liberté leur
liberté chérie les yeux de la tête la
revendique jusqu'à ont donné le nom à
leur dernier album enregistré en 2015 le
groupe parisien était vendredi soir sur
la scène de la vacquerie à guyancourt
qu'on fait passer au public c'est une
envie de partage et d'émotion de
sensations
de s'assumer aussi soi même de se faire
plaisir de se lâcher de vivre et puis
quelques petits messages aussi un petit
peu politique non pas moralisateur mais
voilà on dit un peu ce qu'on pense sur
le monde qui nous entoure soit
[Musique]
tétouan
mélenchon
[Musique]
des textes engagés inspirés par
l'actualité française ou internationale
mais toujours sur des rythmes
entraînants où se mêlent des influences
musicales allant de sanseverino à
brassens on a un gros background chanson
française qui nous a motivés à faire ça
aussi qui nous inspire beaucoup et à
côté de ça il ya des influences aussi
musiques de l'est musique un petit peu
espagnol il ya un jj notre chanteur
compositeur aussi d'écouter un petit nul
qui peut roth et kiko hip hop des fois
il ya des affluences un peu classique
aussi
sympa musette ne s'est pas il ya un peu
de tout quoi nous notre identité c'est
un mélange de tout ça est de faire une
autre chose une bonne humeur que les
yeux de la tête propage depuis dix ans
sur les scènes françaises et
internationales
un anniversaire qu'ils fêteront le 26
novembre prochain dans la capitale
mais l'enfant sorte et edel comme ça